thank everyone good morning everyone in
the commencement theater
we're here on the stage to talk to all
of you who are assembled here and
everybody who is listening in across the
nation and probably across the world and
to give you while you're waiting a
little information about yells
commencement and about what's happening
today where your children are and what
this day is all about I'm penny Lorenz
I'm a teacher at Yale administrator I
was the head of Jonathan Edwards college
and I was sitting here with i'm garth
ross i'm the executive director for the
shworvel center for arts and student
life and a staff member here at the
university and we're really thrilled to
be here I'll bet you all are thrilled
about the weather we are it's a
wonderful day to be in Old Campus you
know we were worried about thunder
lightning it may be hot one thing we do
know is that you people have had a very
long weekend it's a lot of talking a lot
of walking around a lot of exhaustion
and we hope you'll be able to sit back
and enjoy this commentary for a little
while and we'll tell you as much as we
can about where your children are and
what's going on and we hope you could
enjoy the accomplishment that you all
share with all of your graduates today
it's an incredible day for everyone so I
mean this is commencement what does
commencement mean it is a beginning it
is a moment of transition for everyone
who's part of it undergraduates are
going on to a new life graduate students
and professional students are going on
to professional careers but I also think
of it as a day of celebration for the
entire university it's the only day in
which everyone in the university can be
gathered in one place and do you see a
lot of pomp and circumstance Yale is
full of a lot of it and I really think
of it as a celebration
of Education as a kind of moment where
we celebrate transformation and when we
celebrate the age and our belief that
education is transformative
absolutely and penny you mentioned that
this is the one day when we all gather
in one place can you talk about old
campus and how many people are able to
be here together with us today and what
this place means yes
we're so where are we we're sitting on
the old campus it's called the
commencement theater it's only a theater
because we have a lot of chairs here in
a stage otherwise it's not a theater and
if you're sitting here in back of you is
the old the brick building is the oldest
building at Yale it was built in 1701
it's had a bit of transformation since
then and it is the this is the oldest
part of Yale and that's the oldest
building at Yale it now houses the
philosophy department and in the middle
of it it has the faculty room the
important undergraduate faculty room and
so what else is here on the old campus
do you know Garth well I'm quite new to
the university but I understand that all
of our first years live here on old
campus all of them not all okay well but
a good number of them some of the
college's four of them are big enough to
have first year's live rent right inside
them but otherwise everybody is here on
the old campus yes another thing I love
about the old campus is the tradition
that is embedded in the walkways can you
talk a little bit about that the
pathways and how they intersect my
recollection is that the original design
of the old campus quad involved these
intersecting pathways so these students
who had come together from far and wide
wouldn't be able to pass through these
gates and across this quad without
bumping into each other and it's that
sort of intersection that the university
has always been striving for and is
indeed known for more and more each year
as the student body gets more and more
diverse you'll notice a trim
a number of chairs here and the number
of people here gets bigger every year
and we can we can talk about that a
little if you're interested in numbers
how many people are actually going to be
here how many graduates we have about
thirteen hundred and forty
undergraduates and we have about a
hundred and ten from the School of
Medicine fifty-eight from the school of
art 110 from music forestry and
environmental studies has about 150
public health 231 divinity 145 the Law
School has 225 drama 75 and here is that
one of the youngest schools at Yale
management the School of Management has
525 students and it's getting bigger
every year it's incredible I don't know
where we're going to put them later but
we'll see architecture has 75 and the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
which includes people are getting their
masters and their doctorates is 480 and
nursing has 139 for a total of five
thousand 139 graduate professional and
postdoctoral students yeah if you think
about it you know we're not the size of
Ohio State or the University of Michigan
but we're a nice medium sized school but
when you put everybody together
that's quite a quite a few
undergraduates and graduate students and
quite a number of families to put on the
old campus absolutely yeah
you might ask what is this ceremony
you're attending and why are you here
and why are you going to another
ceremony right afterwards
well I think the thing that I would love
to hear about first is where are our
graduates yeah okay
where are our graduates where are your
graduates well they are all lining up a
good part of this program is precession
you will be here those of you who are on
old campus when the procession comes
down this middle aisle here in all its
glory but right now these graduates are
lining up all over campus the
undergraduates are lining up in their
residential colleges the 14 residential
colleges they probably went to bed very
late last night it's been a big week
people are telling them to get dressed
and hurry up and get out they're looking
for their gowns there's always somebody
who didn't order his or her gown and
they're looking around for a gown for
them they're lining up the graduate
students are lining up either in their
schools and processing to the cross
campus or waiting to come in these other
gates of the University on the cross
campus you'll see the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences the School of Medicine the
Yale College Dean's office all the
residential colleges lining up and
people are talking with one another will
be able to see I think some of that on
the screen and in the various schools
people are also lining up and it's a
moment of joyous celebration they're
seeing their friends they're seeing
their teachers and they're having really
a wonderful morning I think you're
sitting here waiting those of you in the
commencement theater but they're
enjoying themselves with their friends
and teachers it really is a beautiful
convening these students spend all year
toiling away and there's separate
colleges and there's separate schools
and on this morning as they all pass
into cross campus
see the banners announcing where each of
the schools and colleges should line up
they come together and gather as this
group of this group of scholars that
really has no parallel yes and no then
you might want to know where is the
president of the university where is the
Dean of the faculty where is the Provost
where are all the Honor ends where are
they they are lining up in Sterling
Memorial Library huh and they're
probably enjoying a cup of coffee and a
little breakfast and they're talking
with one another and they're robing
they're putting on their robes and
they're getting directions about how the
morning will go sure
and eventually they will be the leaders
of the procession the leaders of the
people coming into this commencement
theater but that will be a while from
now now penny you mentioned a few
minutes ago what a busy weekend that
we've all been having already and what's
already happened this weekend is
baccalaureate and and the class day can
you talk about those incredible
ceremonies yes yes so class day was
yesterday afternoon
people often ask does who is Yale's
commencement speaker right and as a
matter of fact no one speaks at a Yale
commencement except the president and
those who are actually conferring
degrees or asking the President to
confer degrees right the only exception
is when a sitting president of the
United States is present and then he or
maybe some day she gets to make a short
short commentary other than that
no one the no one there's no
commencement address however there is a
class day address a class day is
particularly for the undergraduates but
many people show up for the address
even if they do not have children who
were celebrating undergraduate class day
it's very inspiring yes and yesterday we
had Chimamanda Adichie a she was
absolutely wonderful and if you look at
your programs you'll see that today she
is receiving an honorary degree so that
was inspirational and class day is
really a left left over from the days
when there were only about a hundred
people in the class and the day belonged
entirely to the people in the class and
they sat around in a big circle and they
ribbed each other and they told stories
and they sang songs and that's part of
what class day is in the other part of
class day our academic awards heist and
awards awards that are given to the very
very most accomplished people in the
class although of course they represent
others who are extremely accomplished
and that's a residue from the very very
old days in which commencement was
actually a moment when the graduates
spoke and they had to undergo a great
deal of examination from their tutors
and from the president and the residual
of that is some of the speeches that go
on but also the award ceremonies so
class state puts together two very
ancient parts of commencement the part
in the academic part and the part in
which people are celebrating each other
and just having a really good time and
those awards that are conferred at class
day they play into today's ceremony as
well is that right they do because the
people who won what are called The Heist
and awards carries some of the banners
okay but in talking about class today
we're talking only about undergraduates
that's right because all over the campus
yesterday there were other other things
going on
celebrations
gatherings sometimes schools have
special events going on and of course
last night many many many dinners and
other kinds of celebratory events so yes
now the baccalaureate right the
baccalaureate is the leave oh where of
course Yale was a Congregational school
baccalaureate is a leave over from what
were really religious ceremonies and
congregational ceremonies in which the
president of the university who in the
early days was absolutely a preacher
would be giving would be addressing the
graduates the undergraduates and today
this ceremony is not a religious
ceremony but the president always gives
an address the Dean of Yale College
gives some remarks and quotations and it
takes the undergraduates back to their
first moments at Yale when they also sat
in Woolsey Hall and listened to the
president and the Dean and now they're
coming full circle and listening
listening to them again there's a lot of
talking around commencement so the fact
that we don't have a commencement
speaker I think is perfectly fine right
so from here after this ceremony people
will go to another ceremony and maybe we
should talk a little bit about the
difference between them sure I think
that would be great yeah well I did have
a question for you that you use you know
you noted that this day's ceremony is
not characterized by a lot of speaking
although when I think about it I think
that the heraldry and the pageantry of
it has a tremendous amount of embedded
messaging and history and
I'm just curious can you can you talk a
little bit about the the robes and the
collars and things that we will see when
we start to see the graduates and the
faculty process yes
yes so one of the reasons I think Yale
has so much heraldry so many banners so
many maces so many pins so many shields
so much of that is not only that we want
wish to show ourselves in a full pomp
and circumstance in the celebration of
the day but we probably have more than
any other school and that is because we
had what was called a gentleman his name
was tubby sizer Teddy sizer but he was
called tubby who was a historian of art
and he was also one of the monument men
in World War two who after the war began
to look at what what had happened to all
of the great art from the museum
said where it was and to identify it and
to get it back to its original owners
but he was also an expert on heraldry
and so he invented all of these shields
and banners and many of the things that
you see on the mesas and the pageantry
of it is a great part of what is now
yells commencement I don't think you see
quite this much and any other University
there is a great deal of it yeah I've
certainly not seen this level and is
this the title purse we've on yeah the
title is purse we want and if you ask if
we still have a purse we upon't who
deals with a heraldry at yale and all
the banners and what happened when we
had two new residential colleges what
happens when we have a new school who
develops all the banners in Arabic
heraldry for that well most of that is
done now by the University printer who's
John gamble he designed I believe that
Flags for the new colleges the banners
for the new colleges and so it continues
we continue with that tradition which
you'll see in full flourish today on the
screen yes on the screen we just saw a
number of the banners which you'll see
later coming down the walkway it's
fascinating to me how this these banners
and these crests they feel like they've
been around from time immemorial but as
this university continues to evolve so
does the heraldry so of course school of
management is is relatively new and the
crest of Benjamin Franklin and Pauli
Murray are are new as well yes now the
rows here we see some robes on the
screen what about the robes and who
wears what robe well the first thing is
that you don't wear the robe of the
school where you are teaching you'll
always wear the robe
of the institution where you received
your highest degree so I am sitting here
wearing a crimson robe and that's not a
Yale robe it's a Harvard robe even
though I've been at Yale for 45 years
I'm wearing a robe where I received my
PhD and I'm proudly wearing my Bachelor
of Arts row from Connecticut College
right up the coast and you are wearing a
hood which has a white velvet thank you
and you know why well that's for The
Bachelor of Arts correct it's it's
special of arts but it's also it it also
you'll see humanities and liberal arts
awards today and there that will they
will be white
there will be white so you can tell
schools when you see them oh there's
there's the dog there is handsome Dan
ladies and gentlemen handsome Dan is the
Yale mascot the first mascot well he's
not the first well that's true but but
as a tradition the first mascot in any
school yes yes yes oh they say and he's
I think what number Bulldog a CD he's
the 18th got a long line of handsome
dance and his name is Walter and he's
extremely popular and he will be leading
some of the processions ah now we're
beginning to see people process all
right now you see on the gowns they're
wearing these stoles which are called
Tippit's and they have become very very
popular lately they're actually not
really formally allowed and yet Yale has
never done anything about them the
multicolored stones are
probably from the african-american
cultural center graduation and the other
stoles represent the college so here we
see coming in the yellow we see I
believe that's Pearson Pearson is coming
and here they are they're all going to
be processing we haven't talked about
this but they're going to be processing
to line up around the green around the
green now Garth why don't you say
something about why they're going to
line up around the green so if I have my
history correct the procession around
the green commemorates the very first
Yale commencement which was which took
place in the church on the green so to
remember that the undergraduates circled
the green and then the corporation and
the faculty and that process through all
of the undergraduate that's that's
correct
so the it also symbolizes yells
relationship to New Haven and the fact
that the first graduation when it's
actually in the centered church center
church yes which is still there on the
green and by the way which is the fourth
such church to be built in that place on
the green and so they and they actually
built it over a graveyard so you can
visit in the church you can visit the
crypts in the bottom of the church
incredible
but Center Church was where commencement
was first held at Yale and now and
following that it's moved around a
number of times it moved from there to
Battelle chapel which is right here on
the old campus and when people got too
many for Battelle they then moved it to
Woolsey Hall and in 1950 after the war
when so many veterans were coming back
and we
Wolsey all we moved adhere to the old
campus and now you see that is Davenport
coming down and on the other side
Berkeley we have Berkeley yes and you
see that that at the front are the heads
of college and the deans of the college
the banners are carried by marshals who
represent the college and you see all
the faculty in a line coming through
here and after the faculty come the
students
not quite sure we have Davenport no no
Davenport's still coming but I'm sure oh
that is that is Berkeley that's David
Swensen there in Meghan that's that's
Berkeley coming so it's was Berkeley on
the left and Davenport on the right
Berkeley sings to him know the location
we're looking at is the Noah Porter gate
which is right on the edge of across
campus so this is the this is the
beginning of it all yes dollars are
moving and processing towards the green
now the Pete you who are here to see the
your students get graduate and
professional degrees
they do not come through Noah Porter
gate so they will actually be coming
through if you're watching me on either
side of the old campus they'll be coming
through the gates on either side so from
the right you'll see the School of
Medicine and the schools of the Arts
from the left you'll see management and
other professional schools and they'll
all be congregating here it's actually
the undergraduates who are the most
numerous who are lining up around the
green and it's a way of the youngest
students at Yale making a big circle
that the president and members of the
corporation and members of the of the
faculty and Dean's can walk through it's
a lovely tradition walk through the
undergraduates and then musics there's
music and there's music the band is
leading them yes the band is leading
them and the college's line up in two
rows so that the corporation and the
officers can lead us sound between them
led by the band it's just an incredible
now we see on the right I will say the
best college of them all because it's my
College where I was a head of college
for eight years and that's Jonathan
Edwards College on the right wearing the
green stoles and the faculty are coming
through and then the students do you
want to talk about that crest since
we're talking about Jonathan Edwards and
you know it well the crest which is on
the stoles they're wearing is of a lion
rampant okay and that is simply the
symbol there is a long heraldic reason
for that I think it was part of the
crest of Jonathan Edwards himself the
family crest so in some cases these
insignias represent the coats of arms of
the people who started the college but
of course not every colleges name for a
person sure so others were invented for
other reasons and coming up behind I see
Branford and Trumbull
the Bulls on the flag for Trumbull and
the books on the flag for Brantford
symbolizing the books that were first
given to Yale and Brant in Brantford
when when Yale was in Branford
Connecticut Yale moved around quite a
bit before it ended up in New Haven and
this is an interesting thing there was a
big fight about where Yale would end up
and the fight was between Hartford oh
and New Haven and it was really intense
and we know who won and we know who won
but in the first commencement Yale had
in 1718 here it was still not a
completely settled thing about that deal
would be here there were people who were
still fighting to get it to Hartford and
I believe the capital of the state was
being shared back and forth between
those two cities as well one which was
Hartford perceived as the capital of the
interior and New Haven which was the
capital here on the coast yes so we
still see Brantford on the right and I
love the fact that everybody is now
wearing these stoles ten years ago
nobody would have been wearing them well
they're also carrying different things
as well sometimes flags sometimes other
items that symbolize their their schools
I saw the the act with Morris yes
and of course every
procession is led by marshals who do
just what you know they're supposed to
do they marshal and make sure
everybody's in order and make sure oh
well here comes the new college this is
Pauli Murray and Franklin I believe yes
coming down that's right by the way the
gowns you can see there's an MIT gown a
gray one and our another crimson gown
and here come the Pauli Murray students
and Franklin's students they're waving
at you now you know I'm looking at their
mortarboards and of course those are
very important to this day but it's also
reminding me of a tradition on class day
which is the decorating of the house is
that right yes you will see some hats
usually in the professional schools okay
usually in the professional schools now
you can't be sure they'll do it every
year but you'll be able to recognize
forestry and environmental studies
because they're often wearing greens on
the time flowers on the top of their
caps okay the Divinity School sometimes
has halos and you'll be able to see the
extraordinary interest of what some of
the schools do and the degrees are
actually conferred and the marshals all
carry maces yes they all carry maces but
they're maces are often have are
dedicated to what symbols of their
college but we're going to see some very
very very impressive maces later on when
we see the president's party in the
corporation party and those maces are
carried by members of the faculty
usually retiring members of the faculty
who are very distinguished and who have
been chosen to carry the maces on on
this day
and I often like to tell people that
when you get a big award at Yale at
commencement your award is really to
carry either a very heavy banner for a
long distance or a very heavy mace
though one of the maces weighs 24 pounds
the university mace weighs 24 pounds and
sometimes they have a younger person
helping to carry that mace 20 picking up
24 pounds is one thing but carrying it
around for an hour there's another thing
entirely yes mate might say a little bit
more about the hoods and their colors so
when you see these people coming in who
are not undergraduates but are members
of the graduate and professional School
you're going to be able to tell them by
the colors on the hoods that they're
wearing
so when you see architecture when you
see art and drama that will be brown
when you see divinity it will be scarlet
forestry is Russert law will be purple
and when you get a lot of these people
together you'll be able to spot them
very well absolutely and management will
be blue that it'll be a lot of those
there will be a lot of those medicine
green music the musicians wear pink
Nursing wears Africa Public Health wears
a salmon pink and engineering wears
orange so as you see large groups of
people entering they'll be entering from
Miller gate and from High Street you
will be able to spot large numbers of
them by the color of the hoods they're
wearing now I'm wearing a Harvard who at
Harvard's a little different all of the
Harvard hoods are lined with crimson and
the rest is black and you can tell
what's cool by the crow's feet on the
gowns so that is that is actually a
difference if you look at a Harvard
commencement
everybody's wearing the same color looks
everybody looks the same but when they
come in here you'll be able to see
people who are actually different where
is the March now I wonder how are they
doing well this is such a complex day
and who puts it together a penny that's
a good question
this is really like putting on a major
show I know Garth is a theatre person so
you know you always know that when
you're putting on a theater production
it takes a lot of backstage oh that's
right and there is a universe the events
single person who is in charge of this
entire day and a number of other
University events and you know really
putting this all together is a
tremendous tremendous amount of work
gathering people from all over telling
them how to process what to wear right
and then think about it ladies and
gentlemen next you're going to go to
your schools and to the residential
colleges and you're going to have
another ceremony which has a number of
moving parts to it that's right and
think about all the honor rounds you're
going to see we should be talking about
them and oh yeah and getting them all
here to New Haven and making sure
they're well taken care of and feeding
them it's really putting on a major
major major production absolutely
there's I wonder what the total number
of Marshalls
is to put this all together I have no
idea it's any different types of martial
arts for the marshals and it takes a
significant staff and the participation
of a number of people including
facilities they are they really deserve
a hand for taking care of this stage
absolutely all the electronic
broadcasting that needs to take place
all of the tents all of the courtyard
tents all of our police and security
lease and security
yes Rafi to Aryan and Bob Sullivan and
their staff are very very busy getting
the commencement ready and the
landscaping absolutely the grounds - on
the grounds and your sing Yuri and his
staff have done a phenomenal job on
grounds and and not just here in Old
Campus all around the campus and as the
campus spills into New Haven it's just
beautiful this time of year and that's
absolutely no accident it's a tremendous
amount of work to make this so beautiful
for this day so now they're still
marching around the green I think we can
you know say a few words about the honor
ends in the programs you have you'll see
the wonderful biographies somebody had
to put those together and later you'll
hear wonderful tributes to them as the
president Awards them their honorary
degrees but there are some interesting
things to be said about these honorary
degree I think it's a fabulous list this
year a fabulous list it's incredible and
you know I think of all the many things
that we could say about this year's
honor ends one thing that needs to be
said right off the bat is how many women
leaders are represented and how
important that is in this particular
year do you want to say yes the slate is
dominated by influential and powerful
women actually and that is significant
because 2019 2020 are the anniversaries
first of the 50th year of women admitted
to Yale College and that big celebration
will peak take place next September and
then the 150th the anniversary of the
first women woman ever admitted to Yale
and that's to the school of art and so
these celebrations will take place
during the next two years and so it is
it is really wonderful to begin this
year with a slate that includes some
very very significant women among them
Chimamanda Adichie a
who spoke yesterday at class today the
wonderful author and TED talk gives a
very very famous TED talk inspirational
writer and inspirational speaker and
Mary beard that's very close to my heart
because she's a very very great
classicist
as well as a public intellectual and a
feminist Sheila Hicks the artist whose
paintings some of her paintings are at
Yale and she was a Yalie actually and
we're so proud of her and her paintings
all over the world Cynthia Moss oh she's
going to be a great favorite she founded
the elephant project the Ambrose le
elephant project she's a groundbreaking
conservationist extremely wonderful
person and Indra Nooyi the former
president of PepsiCo Lowe who's a Yale
graduate and a member of the corporation
for a number of years and sister Helen
Prejean who has advocated against the
death penalty and has counseled many
many prisoners who were waiting the
death penalty
these are wonderful people and of course
Gloria Steinem the founder of MS
magazine and the great feminist who is
here here with us so that's going to be
great fun now we shouldn't we shouldn't
say that the men are any less wonderful
so we have James Baker former Secretary
of State and we have Larry back out the
new president of Harvard here's an
interesting point the Harvard and Yale
presidents when they become presidents
always get a degree from the sister
institution so you know work very very
competitive with our sister institution
and we are on the field of play always
competitive but we actually
our comrades-in-arms we're comrades in
arms for the sake of education for the
glory that education brings to not only
professional life for the richness of
your entire life
and so it is customary to honor a new
president of Harvard as Harvard
customarily honors a new president of
Yale and I would say that you yourself
embody this great tradition so that I am
a Harvard gown but word you know
delighted to have Larry back out here
absolutely a great honor to have him
come oh I forgot that we forgot I forgot
to mention Carmen to laugh a lot yes oh
my goodness
she is the most marvelous dancer and
choreographer and it's thrilling she has
taught at the Yale School of Drama yes
it's fabulous to have her on the list as
well
and did we forget anyone
oh strive mas eu ah who is the great
philanthropist and business men from
Africa so this is going to be a stunning
list so you would say why are we giving
people these degrees right you know well
I do and I think it speaks to you know
with each description that you shared
you hear the the strength of these
people's values coming through in their
work they're so inspiring and all of
these honor Ann's
exemplify the values of Yale as a
university and inspire our graduates as
they go out into the world what else
would you say let me just say that on
the screen now you see the university's
flag yeah this is the beginning of the
great procession and you see the Yale
flag here being carried and you
see the 24 pound mace being carried by
professor of mathematics
Grisha Margolis there's president
salivate there's the Provost then his
hood was different
whose Oh gross yes the president has a
very special hood and a very special
gown and oh here are the honor ends
there's Carmen de la ville odd they all
have someone with them and here is the
Yale corporation they're all dressed in
the Yale corporation gowns oh and there
is ya Chimamanda Adichie a and there and
I see James Baker
I see members of the corporation here
all all marching and now we see the the
Dean of the college
Marvin Chun women purple and red robes
oh that he's wearing an MIT robe yes
this is Yale College here comes the L
College there's the Dean of Admissions
jeremiah quinlan mark Shanker all the
deans the dean of students all of the
deans of yale college are now marching
in and the banner they was we're
carrying was the banner of the entire
Yale car and here is Mary Miller the
former dean of the Yale College who just
retired
she's the marshal for the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences the Dean of the
Faculty of Arts and Science Tamar
Gendler Amie Hungerford one of the
deputy deans and the whole panoply of
the Faculty of Arts and Sciences is here
and now we really see the difference in
the robes in the hoods yes so the
faculty are all rearing the hoods from
their colleges you see a lot of blue the
light blue is Columbia the orange is
Princeton then people are wearing some
are wearing black gowns with their red
hoods I see quite a bit of Princeton
there and I see an Oxford gown coming
along you see some of the international
gowns
so when you when you see a lot of
different colors when you're looking at
the faculty penny it's such a pleasure
to to do this with you and to make
commentary on these images because it's
just an incredible stream of humanity
and you you really understand what we're
looking at here so thank you very well
Garth it's wonderful to have you here
too I mean we should say that you're
going to be the head of the Schwartzman
Center which is going to open in about a
year that's right and it's the going to
be a great great space let's see here
come more of the University flags the
college flags the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences School of Arts and
Sciences so here are all the people the
faculty first well here's the School of
Medicine's right that's the Green School
of Medicine on the left so now we're
starting to see the graduate students
yes I'm well thank you hi hi professor
May you were on we're on live stream
here we're on we're on the live stream
here yes we are yes we are so well we
are in a minute so professor Mayhew is
one of our very very stinglash political
scientists and he's walking onto the
stage we'll have an incredible group up
on that stage yes the people on the
stage will be the Ameri tie who have
chosen to sit here I see I saw a few
here already and the Yale corporation
the honor ends and all the deans
sitting there and here comes in the blue
hood again well this is the Graduate
School of Arts and Science right thank
you
and these are still lettuce unless that
is now management I'm not sure I didn't
see the flags come no I didn't die there
but these are still graduates coming out
of cross campus so a lot of the graduate
professional schools are our staging are
across campus as well so it's just a
they haven't started coming in yet so
you see how it does take a very long
time to get everybody in here so
actually the real event begins at 11:00
we try to begin it may be a little
before but right now you're seeing this
incredible procession of five five
thousand graduates from everywhere there
you see music that's right the pink
hoods it's amazing that all these people
are getting graduate degrees
so I haven't we haven't seen the
president yet or the president's party
but when you see them so we said we saw
him come by very briefly and mentioned
the the hood that the president is
wearing so we're gonna see that again
later can you talk a little bit about
that because it's really extraordinary
it's a very special gown that's created
for the president that he wears all the
time he wears a very special collar
collar thank you very very special
collar that has the names of all of the
schools on it and it was actually once
here's a little bit of history stolen
from the president's office in 1979 oh
my gosh when by somebody left a vault to
open and it was taken and it was
recreated as a gift from a donor and he
was you will see him wearing it with his
special gown all around his neck and
right now you'll see filing into the
cross campus in front of the stage
though I don't think you can see it a
lot of the faculty from the schools who
are beginning I see the deans the school
management and I see the resident some
of the graduate school deans have come
to put their mesas up and to take their
places and all of the faculty will be
seated in the very very front of the
commencement Theatre right in front of
the stage and behind them and to the
sides of them will be the undergraduates
and all the schools and eventually all
of the flags will be positioned right in
front of the stage yes they will there
will be a big ceremony my favorite part
of the day and I think you'll enjoy it
too is when the flags come down this
center aisle and you'll hear the schools
and the colleges which
which these flags represent yelling and
cheering happily to see their school
being represented
so here come people I can't see quite
what that color is that I think it's our
orange it may be architecture that's
coming it's all the salmon pink in the
Ark I think that's architecture I didn't
see who was at the head of the
procession I wasn't looking just
beginning to come in just beginning to
come in and so for those of you who
weren't here in the beginning I think
it's worth saying again that what is
happening now outside the gates besides
the fact that the professional schools
are entering is that the corporation
party the president the Faculty of Arts
and Science and the Yale College Dean's
office are all processing through the
undergraduates the the fellows of the
colleges and they're greeting them
they're saying good morning they're
exchanging hellos here's a wonderful
yeah beginning to see that my food is
cheering everybody and saying hello what
an accomplishment
okay here comes law yeah wearing purple
yeah here they come the law school
headed by Mike Mike Thompson the long
serving marshal Guido Calabresi there
wearing his Italian gown
[Music]
Heather gherkin who is the new dean of
the School of Law I see and here come
the law school graduates and here comes
divinity on the other side yes
there there's wearing the scarlet here
comes divinity and Dean sterling yes
that's the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences hello Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences
you look wonderful in your blue yay and
we're starting to hear the music yes
the band is beginning to lead people
through the gates so as soon as the
people start coming down this aisle
Garth and I will disappear and it will
still take time for all the people to to
enter here here comes the band to Phelps
gate and there's the mace still held
high
[Music]
I think they're not coming down the
aisle yet are they no not down the aisle
just just through the gate here's the
art this is ROTC or the this is the
flags
[Music]
coming to Louisville ah yes here comes
the corporation
are they coming down
and good afternoon everyone have a
wonderful commencement
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to the students of the class of 2019 and
their parents families and friends
welcome to the 318 commencement of Yale
University we gather to recognize the
extraordinary accomplishments of all of
you who have worked so hard to complete
your programs of study we salute your
effort your diligence your talent and
your intellect we also join you in
expressing gratitude for all who have
supported you in these endeavors your
families and friends teachers and other
members of the Yale community in keeping
with the tradition of this occasion I
now call on the University chaplain to
offer an invocation with deep gratitude
to the Quinnipiac people for this land
on which we stand
my beloved Yale family I invite you to
join me in the spirit of Prayer Almighty
and loving Creator you are the force
that lights the Stars the architect of
every cell the source of all truth we
stand in the dazzling beauty of this
morning as many living expressions of
one mystery a mystery beyond all telling
we who share
this beautiful but aching world we who
look at the same Sun and the same moon
are a people called to communal
restoration as students of your
handiwork
we have gathered here from throughout
the earth with exquisite ambitions and
have blessed at this place with the job
of seeking your light and your truth our
God of all generations you are the
guardian of where we are going and who
we are becoming as we prepare to take
leave of this space
may we exude an intelligence that is
inspired by justice guided by tenderness
moved by holiness and always informed by
love
from this moment of awe and beyond fill
our hearts with an imaginative daring
one that stirs us to become a living and
vibrant example of Shalom of Salaam of
Shanthi of peace together we say Amen
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the bachelor's
degrees in Yale College for the degree
of Bachelor of Arts 844 in number and
for the degree of Bachelor of Science
503 in number they have been recommended
by the Faculty of Yale College and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees
[Applause]
[Music]
by the authority by the authority vested
in me I confer upon you the bachelors
degrees in yell college as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Architecture for the degree of
Master of Architecture 70 in number and
for the degree of Master of
Environmental Design five in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in
architecture and design as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
school of art for the degree of Master
of Fine Arts fifty eight in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them this
degree by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degree in art as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all its rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Drama for the certificate in
drama 4 and number 4 the degree of
Master of Fine Arts 49 in number and for
the degree of Doctor of Fine Arts 2 in
number they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the certificate and
degrees in drama designated by the Dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the degrees in
the School of Music for this certificate
in performance one in number for the
artists diploma one in number for the
degree of Master of Music
74 in number for the degree of master of
musical arts 28 and number and for the
degree of Doctor of Musical Arts 6 in
number they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the certificate diploma
and degrees in music as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present to you candidates for degrees in
the School of Nursing
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
for the degree of Master of Science in
Nursing 112 in number for the
postgraduate APR and certificate in
nursing - in number and for the degree
of Doctor of Nursing Practice 16 in
number they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in nursing
as designated by the Dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Forestry and environmental
studies
[Applause]
for the degree of Master of Forestry 11
in number for the degree of Master of
forest science 4 in number for the
degree of Master of Environmental
Management 113 in number and for the
degree of Master of Environmental
Science 29 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in forestry and environmental
studies as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Management for their degree of
Master of Business Administration 394 in
number for the degree of Master of
Advanced Management 69 in number and for
the degree of Master and Management
Studies 42 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in management as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
Divinity School for the degree of Master
of Arts in religion 69 in number for the
degree of Master of Divinity 49 in
number and for the degree of Master of
sacred theology 14 in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
grant them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degrees in religion divinity and
theology as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
law school for the degree of Juris
Doctor 212 in number for the degree of
Master of Laws twenty-eight in number
and for the degree of doctor in the
science of law two in number when they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I shall ask you by your
official act to occur for upon them
these degrees by the authority vested in
me I shall confer upon you the degrees
in the law school when designated by the
Dean and shall then admit you to all
their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
graduate school for the degree of Master
of Advanced Study - in number for the
degree of Master of Science well 295 in
number for the degree of Master of Arts
279 in number and for the degree of
Master of Philosophy 381 in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in the
Graduate School as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the degrees in
the School of Public Health to 229 in
number
they've been recommended by the Faculty
of this school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them this
degree by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degree in public
health as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all its responsibilities
its rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Medicine for the degree of
master of medical science 40 and number
when they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I shall ask by your
official act to confer upon them this
degree for the certificate in global
medicine 1 in number for the degree of
master of health science 35 in number
and for the degree of Doctor of Medicine
87 in number they have been recommended
by the Faculty of the school and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I shall confer the degree
in medical science and do confer upon
you the certificate and degrees in
global medicine health science and
medicine as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
prices clarice eBay
[Applause]
candidatos odd gradum filosophy a Taurus
numero Quadron Genting sex TB price on
toe a faculty a filosophy eye
Artyom Quay at obscenity académico
illusory a pro body soon take domine
Rogo a odd hunk Graydon admit us
[Music]
[Applause]
secundum legis moran quail universitatis
nostril worse ad gradum philosophy i
doctores emitter whoa Bisquick wanna
come hook diplomat a Yura illa at way
dignitaries qui Eric on or expectant
conferral long study East fella kata
absolutists ego Rises Oona where'sa
Tatars woods and animal yo Bey Oh Sal
where a it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we will now proceed to the awarding of
honorary degrees the 11 individuals we
honor this morning serve as examples to
you our graduates to encourage you to
aspire to excellence and to value those
elements of human character that they
embody creativity curiosity discipline
integrity and a passion for public
service their presence here also honors
you who graduate today and all of us who
are here to salute you
I will now as is customary call upon the
Provost to present the candidates for
honorary degrees mr. president I have
the honor to present the candidates for
honorary degrees for the degree of
Doctor of social science Lawrence
s ba cow scholar
Lauren says baka Vanguard of Veritas you
champion the promise and responsibility
of higher education to seek truth expand
opportunity and contribute to the
greater good from Pontiac Michigan to
the banks of the Charles River you have
acquired a shem tov a good name by
acting with wisdom and integrity
we proudly welcome you to the Yale
family as we confer on you
this doctor of social science degree
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Divinity
sister Helen Prejean death penalty
abolitionists
[Applause]
sister Helen Prejean emissary of hope
you go to the margins of society to the
poor forgotten and alone to share God's
love in bearing witness and raising your
voice you have changed hearts
transformed catechism and opened our
eyes to the value of all human beings no
matter who they are or what they have
done in appreciation for your mission of
justice and mercy we humbly present you
with this Doctor of Divinity degree
for the degree of Doctor of Fine Arts
Carmen de la Villard
performing artists
[Applause]
grand-am of dance you are a regal
storyteller working in the medium of
movement from Broadway to Hollywood from
the Yale rep to the Metropolitan Opera
audiences have fallen under your
magnificent spell enchanted by your
grace and skill choreographer and
teacher actress and artists an
appreciation for your pioneering
creativity on many stages we proudly
bestow on you this Doctor of Fine Arts
degree
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of humanities
Mary beard classicists
berry beard scholar of the people you
excavate the past and challenge our view
of the present with honesty humor and
brilliance you find fresh insights in
the collected corners of antiquity and
stimulate debate in modern forums
fearless thinker curious guide for
inspiring us to look anew at History and
ourselves we are privileged to award you
this Doctor of humanities degree
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters strive Messier entrepreneur and
philanthropist strive merci WA you see
opportunities others myths and
demonstrate the courage of your
convictions at every turn
brave visionary bold business leader and
devoted humanitarian your innovation and
generosity have transformed a continent
and improved countless lives for
inspiring us to tackle great challenges
lead with honor and serve others Yale is
privileged to confer on you this Doctor
of Humane Letters degree
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Fine Arts
Sheila Hicks artists
Shiela Hecht's weaving global traditions
you fashion masterpieces of texture
color structure and scale that are
uniquely your own in your hands fiber
and found objects are transformed
confounding categories and elevating our
public spaces in gratitude for the
beauty and meaning you have knitted
together in a lifetime of sublime work
we are delighted to present your third
Yale degree Doctor of Fine Arts
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters Indra koe business leader
[Applause]
Indra Nooyi intrepid Trailblazer you
have led with purpose ascending the
corporate ladder and encouraging women
and girls to picture themselves in the
c-suite with brilliance and fortitude
you have embraced changed seized
opportunities and set an enduring
example of success global role model and
recognition of your achievements in
business and forced society we are
honored to present you with your second
degree Doctor of Humane Letters
[Music]
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters Gloria Steinem women's rights
advocates
gloria steinem you spearheaded a
movement and changed our world giving
women greater freedom to chart their own
courses in life opening doors for
generations to come
you fought to expand rights and advance
liberty equality and humanity feminist
and firebrand icon and iconoclast Yale
is proud to award you the degree of
Doctor of Humane Letters
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters James a baker the third public
servant
James Baker as cabinet secretary foreign
envoy and trusted advisor you have
placed national interests above
self-interest your laser sharp
understanding of people power and policy
helped guide a generation of US
presidents shaping our government and
our world in recognition of your
steadfast commitment to this country and
its democratic institutions Yale is
honored to bestow on you the degree of
Doctor of Humane Letters
for the degree of doctor of social
science Cynthia Moss wildlife researcher
Cinthia mas you have brought
international attention to the elephants
of Amboseli through research and
advocacy you show us how these majestic
animals live love and die and the
lessons they offer to humankind
for your extraordinary efforts to
conserve wildlife and its habitats and
for helping us find beauty dignity and
joy beyond our species we are honored to
bestow on you this doctor of social
science degree
and for the degree of Doctor of Letters
Chimamanda Adichie a author
[Applause]
Chimamanda Adichie egg your stories of
war migration home and heartbreak brings
the great richness and multiplicity of
human experience to life with courage
and clarity you call us to do better for
women and girls for ourselves and future
generations around the globe an
appreciation for your superb talent and
leadership in literature and the public
sphere we are honored to present your
second Elle degree Doctor of Letters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I invite you to pray with me God our
places of origin vary but our source is
one the expressions of our humanity are
diverse yet you O God are in all our
perspectives differ but may our hopes
for the world be one bless these
graduates with eyes to see what we have
not seen with minds to grasp what we
have found incomprehensible with hearts
willing to risk failure to change what
we have been unable to alter thank you
for the families and friends who have
brought these graduates to this day for
the faculty and honorees who have
changed our world and for this special
place that we know as Yale that brings
us all together on this day amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]